it is an angry scene on Israel's border
with Gaza nearly 70 miles from Jerusalem
that's where thousands of Palestinians
are protesting the embassy move in the
face of Israeli troops Holly Williams is
in Gaza where officials say at least 16
people have now died in today's violence
Holly good morning
good morning this week marks the
culmination of six weeks of protests
here in the Gaza Strip and today there
are thousands of Palestinians
demonstrating all along the fence just
behind me that separates guards are from
Israel today Israeli soldiers have used
drones to drop tear gas canisters and
fired live ammunition they've killed
more than 40 Palestinian protesters over
the last six weeks most of the
Palestinians here today are peaceful but
some are attempting to cross the border
they're throwing stones and lighting
fires and on Friday some of them stormed
a border crossing point for cargo and
damaged fuel and gas pipelines the
Palestinians have condemned the move of
the US Embassy to Jerusalem in part
because they hope that East Jerusalem
will one day be their capital if they
ever get their own state these protests
also mark the 70th anniversary of the
founding of the State of Israel which
the Palestinians call a catastrophe
these demonstrations seem to be fuelled
by feelings of impotent anger that the
blockade of the Gaza Strip in place for
more than ten years now has left the
economy here on the verge of full
collapse according to the United Nations
with frequent power cuts contaminated
water and nearly 50 percent unemployment
Nora all right Holly Williams in Gaza
thank you